Now let us look at examples that are even more interesting than previously.
Recall that earlier we were talking about background knowledge.
Let's see what role background knowledge plays more explicitly. So
imagine this is the fourth example that the teacher gives to the AI program, and
this is a positive example. So the AI program may have this as the input
representation. There are two bricks, this brick is left of the other brick,
there's a wedge on top, the two bricks are supporting the wedge. So now the AI
program has this as the current definition, recall the not touches links here,
and this is the new example. And this is the positive example. How may the AI
program revise its current concept definition to include this positive example?
Well the simplest in the AI program I do is to replace this brick here,
in the current concept definition by brick or wedge. So
that makes sure that a new example is included in the definition of the concept.
We'll call this the enlarge-set heuristic. This particular set here, which had
only brick here as an element, now has two elements in it; brick or wedge.